hey everybody out there welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
are you garbage I am your host H Foley
coming at you from beautiful Astoria
Queens in New York where the bodies are
stacking hi my friends it's getting a
little dicey in the neighborhood
my co-host bugged out of town at the
first sign of trouble he's coming at you
from an undisclosed location somewhere
in southern New Jersey 222 Wildwood
Crest you keep your [ __ ] mouth shut
jerk-off down there on Coors like party
ball way everybody hey happy to be here
guys thanks for tuning in thanks for you
know all the all the new listeners and
stuff like that we appreciate all the
new subscribers please make sure you
rate review subscribe on iTunes you can
subscribe on youtube for the full video
as well and we appreciate all the
support guys very nice and of course our
very special guest today we are so happy
to have him here our good pal and
incredibly funny stand-up comedian Kippy
check out this [ __ ] rap sheet on this
[ __ ] guy you guys got some comedy
live going back you got comedy knockout
this week at the Comedy Cellar
he's got his own special on Comedy
Central called all save this which broke
every single digital download record
that those [ __ ] bozos and [ __ ]
smashed it open
good night tours all over the world
tours with mr. Bill burr has his own
podcast called the virzi effect on all
things comedy and is gonna be in the
brand new Judd Apatow Pete Davidson
movie that was supposed to be coming out
at South by Southwest
but the corona [ __ ] had something to
say about that but it's gonna be in
theaters very soon ladies and gentlemen
the kid mr. Paul virzi everybody oh wow
thank you for that that was uh I wish my
wife heard that got a little [ __ ]
respect over here cursing me while she's
working from home dealing with the kids
and you're up here you know yelling at
some of my accolades great to be here
with you guys man it's all true my
friend you know how much we love you
all those accomplishments point it's
unbelievable we
to find out are you garbage huh I don't
think so man I've yeah I've traveled
with mr. versi you know we've done a lot
of shows together the guy is all class
through and through that's what I think
I think he might have been you might
have had some garbage tendencies growing
up you know yeah I mean are you from it
you're from Jersey right you were
actually born in Yonkers I'm a
Westchester
why got a lot of people think I'm from
Jersey because I always [ __ ] on it so
since I always [ __ ] on it bill Bert
that's yeah called me the pride of
Trenton which we found out a lot
especially like the white suburbs
outside of a city there's a lot of
trashy characteristics in those families
like we're both from outside Philly and
there's a lot of trashy tendencies that
you know when somebody in the family
gets a couple of bucks and they move out
to like West Chester or somewhere or
Long Island or something they don't
shake the trashiness yeah dude it's
there it's there you can you can try to
hide it with the Lexus's and the big
West Chester and the cats and the dogs
but I think deep down he's got a little
stank on my thing sorry it's a great eye
Paul has always come across to me he
looks like a guy to me that irons is
underwear like everything's tight the
sneakers are always fresh nice t-shirt
nice watch on it's [ __ ] classy nice
and I know his situation now his wife
and his kids that's a that's a tightly
run organization out there yeah and and
for as much as I you know what that's
actually a really good that's really a
good like way to look at it but my wife
is totally the general you show me you
Stan
that trickles down a little bit like yes
I do like a clean pair of cakes yes I do
like what my little wife you want to
talk about a tight ship and you guys
will you guys will meet her I want you
guys to come up here whenever this
madness is over but life better not [ __ ]
around yeah you met her you met her at
dog
I met her yeah yeah yeah um when you see
her in her element like when you watch
her like discipline the kids but also
like
like host a party it's like Jordan and
96 like Jordan 96 like just killing that
the Jazz like that's her yeah see but I
think that counts I think I think that
elevates you 100 percent a little
elevation of certain way and it takes
you out of the garbage status and also
the vibe I get from you and talking to
you is your mom ran a tight ship didn't
you you grew up living with your mom and
your parents or the horse correct yeah
parents got divorced when I was five my
brother was 10 my mother remarried you
know and my stepfather's been in my life
basically since I'm whatever like five
six years old and yeah I mean my mom and
I always had a cool hat always had a
cool relationship my mom but I got the
vibe that you learned a lot from her and
that you you're the way you are because
of her and that she wrote she ran a
tight ship growing up I don't you know
what just be in my head just kiss could
be the storyline I made a man about you
I also paint her as an amazing cook is
that true
well here's the thing yes you know she's
definitely a good cook tight ship here's
the thing my mom kind of felt bad about
the divorce mm-hmm when I acted up you
know when I got arrested or when I was
doing the stupid [ __ ] that I was doing
with the drinking and the partying yes
she like disciplined me but she more
came at me hurt like I'm why is this
happening and like she kind of was like
like I didn't get hit like my mom what
the only time she hit me she just lost
it and she broke a vacuum over my back
Jesus right and he was low my whole
investigation here keep a lid on it
William but you know what me and my mom
you know really did have to save your
theory me and my mom really did have a
have like this kind of special
relationship and bond where whenever I
would go through things and here's the
thing about me dude and we'll get into
it with your game I did some really
[ __ ] up [ __ ] and I did some things
that I'm not proud of and I did some
things that if my children did I would
be like oh my god but during all of that
getting arrested doing juvenile
delinquent [ __ ] when I was younger they
were like yeah but he's respectful which
is but teachers teachers would be like
he's
like the nicest we love somewhat like he
like robbed the cafeteria he's like he's
taking us he's skimming the cafeteria
registers but he is shaking everybody's
hand on the way out he's a good [ __ ]
guy that mercy versus [ __ ] Jimmy the
jet over here dude I remember one time
there was this dude and I don't want to
say names cuz they listen to this [ __ ]
but there was this kid he was bigger
bigger than me Italian kid and he made
fun of this girl that I went to school
with she had really bad eyesight she was
almost like legally blind and when
you're in middle school and the book is
this close people would make funny and I
remember one time she was like crying
and she's like he made fun of me he said
this and I called the [ __ ] kid over
and I was like you're not talked to you
for talked to you first I believed the
bully I made him get on all fours and he
had to bark like a dog in front of all
the 7th graders that is some [ __ ]
Guinea [ __ ] right there I love it
Paul put stemis espresso it was like
what do you say to my parents you're
like well wait a minute
you stop the bullying yeah one hand
washes the other what do you want from
me very Bronx Tale so you're new what so
like when you were younger and you would
hijack like a truck of cigarettes to
make sure you stop the driver 50 bucks
yeah and then he goes into a diner
blames it on a black guy I didn't know
any of this would you believe this
juvenile delinquency this case over here
oh man yeah if you were Mike if you were
my attorney we would be going down for
real ha ha ha
well it Foley's your attorney you're in
bad shape for even if it's a parking
ticket merci your [ __ ] can I tell you
how classy this guy is we you know we
were we were in useless ladies we were
in Houston and you know you go on the
road on people to garlotte's go to a
dive bar a titty bar something he's no
you
told me that she wouldn't get a nice
dinner would you guys go Capital Grille
or something like Lux true yeah true
lots but even before that that was just
like that just happened kind of you know
sporadically after the first night let's
go he's like he's like looking up nice
wine bars we go to this place we order
like a $70 cheese and meat board you
know what I mean we got he's he's
tasting red wines and Cabernets and [ __ ]
I'm like I'm like I can get used to this
[ __ ] oh dude we were loving that night
because he's gonna taste this meat tail
this meat right here with that cheese
forget about it yeah meanwhile he's just
[ __ ] casing the joint trying to alibi
for something for all we know you know
what it you know what it is though man
like I came up and I stayed in those
shitty condos mm-hm and I I would like
you know make that feature money which
was like and sometimes when you're a new
feature they're like yeah we'll give you
a four hundred for the weekend but you
gotta get here so you're eating so bad
and shitty and I always said to myself
when I get to a certain point of my
career you know all those beatings I'm
gonna try to mend those by doing this
yeah it's like listen I got a wife and
kids so me and you going with cigar
lounge even though it happened to be in
all black which was the dude which was
the most insane us realizing we were in
an all-black club it was one of the
scariest turned amazing times ever
because we decide cuz we were at the
club we do not do a time producer yeah
um so I'm like dude let's go to a cigar
lounge I was like we're in Houston let's
go to a cigar lounge and and Kevin is
like which I love why why I love working
with Kevin not only is he [ __ ]
hilarious but he's kind of like is my
speed so I'm like dude let's go to a
cigar lounge we'll get a couple of
drinks smoke a cigar and he was yeah so
we get in this uber and all of a sudden
the guy turns down the block and he's
like yeah it's right there it's not a
good block I gotta go yeah it looked
like it looked like it was a little do
you sure we're in the right look it
looked like one of the streets from
Friday you know what I mean I was with
[ __ ] I was waiting for big worms
on the street in the ice-cream van I
like Paulie trying to dance around a
little bit it was like it was like in
vacation when they wrote honky lips on
it yeah so um we get there and they're
like people outside smoking and you know
me and Kevin are the only white people
there which was totally fine but then we
go in and we realize not only is this
cuz a lot of cigar lounges especially in
New York City to are definitely like
urban crowd or you know what I mean yeah
yeah let's be honest dude black dudes
know how to relax
I feel good recliner when they see one
daddy okay those leather chairs were
perfect dude they got the game on
they're like let's you know let's bring
our friends we'll have a good time so we
go in there but not only is it like a
club it's a member Club and then it was
like the United Negro Chamber of
Commerce and they had like a wall of
fame yeah and there's just all these
head shots and the guy like me Kevin
were like you guys like mind if we're
here yeah every dude it was like we it
was like we broke into the n-double-a-cp
we're like having cigar awesome the
castell what's happening listen anything
you want just go in there like and then
like there were like
local politicians coming in and like
shaking hands yeah it was one of the
funniest things ever and I don't know if
Kevin if you remember this we're sitting
in a private room which was in the
humidor remember yeah sky walks in and
goes hey man what's going on man nice to
meet you he's shaking everybody's hand
and he shakes our head goes yeah you
know I'm running for town mayor or
whatever and me and Kevin like joke will
tell people man I try to get jealous cuz
now I'm gonna win next year yeah good
luck he's like I don't matter I'm gonna
win that [ __ ] anyway he's got a big
cigar there's nothing I don't [ __ ] him
out it was great such a good time yeah
there was like an event there like
there's some quesadillas in the corner
so like dude were eating old quesadillas
and like we're making an old
in the corner of this and like ever all
these life is just looking at these two
random white guys in their club eatin
[ __ ] that was a night to remember how
nice they treated us and how great that
place was it was they were like I don't
know I guess it was like southern
hospitality too were like you would like
go order a drink and we're so like New
York like yeah let me get two beers and
you like walk away they were like how do
you want this do you want that how's
your night you look like you'd have a
five-minute conversation five-minute
conversation get a drink I walked out of
the humidor to the bathroom and the
bartender yelled over to me like oh man
you guys need something you good I was
like oh my god yeah it was great I loved
a lot of their hospitality we were on
the job yeah I'm not seeing any garbage
there that that's rude I'm surprised
about these antics but let's get into
the game here let's ask a couple of
questions we're gonna find out what's
what okay all right all right Kippy do
you want to you can you can go buddy I
wouldn't work backwards a little bit
because like I said I know the household
gear and now is run very tight yes
that's the image I get of you and I know
you said your wife is a large component
of that but you know don't sell yourself
short you you know you it you would have
to be too otherwise she's got just one
extra kid because it's you know you had
said something that I don't think is
garbage but people might think is
garbage I remember you saying you
remember when you said that they left
the pizza out for you on the counter yes
yes I'm a bit listen any leftovers it's
like dinner's being made and I'm coming
home a couple hours later that's just
because you can eat it faster you fat
[ __ ] idiot well once you put pizza in
the fridge it's a whole you can still
capture that freshness of when the pile
is ordered Foley's what do you think I'm
gonna open a door yeah well I want to
open a door and in a box and then put it
in the oven with you nuts it's not
it's the process of refrigeration things
like that made me in dear - mercy but
like I said I want to work back I'm
dragging on here yeah what are you
talking enjoy it with something Jesus
for you talking about pizza let's go you
ever hired a local clown to perform at
your kid's birthday party rias question
I have not
dude growing up there the kid on a kid
on my in my neighborhood his mom was the
local clown giggles mrs. Conover dude
and act she would come to the school and
I could that poor kid got [ __ ]
roasted all day long I felt bad for him
but Jesus Christ mom's the clown that's
a tough law I just pictured him
screaming at her saying can you stop
[Laughter]
juggling and [ __ ] that's just a shade
under prostitute like if you found out
your mother was turning tricks or she's
the local clown
there's something about the turning
tricks that you're a cynic a little more
there's a little more secrecy to it at
least at least not everybody knows you
know what I mean all right what was your
first car my first car was a Ford
Festiva the tiny tiny two-door there was
uh there was a it had know a lady in
Florida had to get rid of it when she
wasn't well air conditioner stole the
tiny two-door mint-condition we got it
for 800 bucks when I was 16 oh man
that's kind of fun for you you live in
Westchester New York how do you get a
car from Florida this lady
I guess it's garbage whatever the answer
is it's if you're buying a car [ __ ]
12 states away some things aren't going
that well no here's what happened my
stepfather drove you yes he met this
lady and he was like wow that Ford is
like brand-new condition she goes yeah
I'm going to Florida I can't take it it
doesn't have an air conditioner okay
then he goes oh my
par and she was like which pretty much
brand-new eight hundred bucks and the
thing was mint that's a good deal right
there I can take its thing my friends
you know beat the [ __ ] out of me and
broke my balls because it was tiny and
small I remember they called it the
pimple they said I was driving what
color was it it was it was like a it was
like a maroon ish birdie
it's only self when you can't pinpoint
the exact color of your car like what
college like well it's kind of like a
deal when you can't just say it's red or
tan or blue it's [ __ ] yeah inside
that car Paul did you have a did you
have any fuzzy dice hanging or did you
have the Italian before I was never the
only thing I ever hung up in any car
would be one of those like little tree
air fresheners okay classy trashy I say
very respectable at the car wash it's
still the [ __ ] best the best idea to
go with the tree I love this ring yeah I
was more of the scent in the car
smelling don't get me wrong some of them
I would go like the Cologne scent yeah
I've done that too like when I know
fuzzy dice balls no disco ball no no
nothing like that would make lights you
know the way people no lights no dice
nothing like that and no Italian horns
nothing like that
did you put did you put a sound system
or speakers or a head unit in that car I
had a full fledge I had the amplifier
system in my car that was more than my
car
yeah oh man that is pure trash right
there
but see listen I got one for you now I
don't know how you guys on your show by
the way your podcast is dope Thanks it's
just fun it's just fun riffing about the
you know because I feel like I'm being
interrogated
I got your fingerprints all over a hefty
bag right now
Society o'clock but not but um I got one
for you and I want to ask you guys on
your show how would you categorize this
are you ready mm-hmm I go to a casino
with two of my buddies okay I'm probably
just I'm under 20 at the time no no no
I'm so yeah I'm 17 at the time go to a
casino it's my buddy's Mohegan Sun it
was right when three-card poker first
came out you guys are three-card poker
right yeah I go with my buddy
I end up winning $2,000 on a hand
because I kept getting a flush and my
buddy who next to me who was kind of a
gambling degenerate at the time goes
dude [ __ ] this I'm going 50 on the next
one we keep getting flushes I go I'm
with you I put down 50 a straight flush
pays 40 to 1 so I have so to brand I
hidden I'll never forget the cards
it was Queen King ace diamonds I'm gonna
do two when he flips it over I think I'm
[ __ ] one flips it over to whole table
goes nuts 2 grand here's what I do I
take 100 of the 2 grand I give it to my
friend for just being next to me during
that moment class act right there I take
another one go to my other friend who
was gambling and say here man you came
this is a hundred for you then I take a
hundred and I play roulette and lose it
now I have 17 I cashed out and I bought
myself a Toyota Tercel which lasted me
for three years after that oh is that it
so it's half garbage but then it's half
kind of like Oh what is that that's I
mean that's pretty trashy to be honest
with you I'm the only people that know
they drove Toyota Tercel 'z were not
upstanding citizens they used to buy me
beer back in the day that's true
oh they give it to you on the Trishelle
I think everything that you said in that
story was a hundred percent classy
except for the fact that you knew the
cards that were flush you know about 15
or so years ago
I got $600 in my pocket do you remember
the first girl you made out with or the
first time you had sex
oh remember the first time you went to
Grande at 17 years old that's true I'll
give you that I'll give you that I'll
give you I don't was a big gambler - I
get it I get it when you're 17 and you
get 15 bucks you're like you're like
we're going to the movies and McDonald's
yeah I know but dude there's nothing
good about that story there's no lucky
and then we went to the ritz-carlton it
was with the Mohegan Sun underage to
plug in three card poker your jerk-off
buddies went 2 grand and you buy a used
car like there's no there's no like
premier thing about that what you do it
to feed it the only thing that would
have been worse if I was like and then
we went to an OTB then we went to a
cockfight you know all right I got
another one have you ever eaten at a
strip club
I think they asked me to and I refused
it I was I was I was super super young
and they had like a Delhi Delhi you
could do a steak chicken finger
something you can't do sliced meats I
deflected I walked into a strip club and
see a Boar's Head counter [ __ ] I saw
a guy in strip club when I was young
eating a salad dude it was the [ __ ]
grossest thing I'm not even joking
I actually got nauseous and said to my
friend you have to leave no I mean like
they had like a dressing station oh
that's the grossest thing I've ever
heard that's oh
all right Foley what do you got that's
[ __ ] a little bit you grew up in an
apartment house would you grow up there
Paul
when they
when they got divorced it went from a
really nice house to me and my brother
living with my mom in an apartment okay
and then when she got remarried um an
apartment for a little bit and then
moved upstate to a house okay and any
time in that journey was there ever any
did you have a porch anywhere a little
back stoop or something like that um
when they first got divorced when I was
younger like elementary school we had a
thing where you walked out and it was
kind of like a patio on the second floor
was it covered in astroturf that's a
tough look I got it you just freaked me
out
[Laughter]
Wow man like first of all and the way
you creepily looked into the zoom and
pointed with the pen and goes now let me
ask you Paul like like I'm getting
interrogated it did it did because um
but here's the thing it was like a nice
neighborhood so but maybe it was like I
don't know like if I was there was a
green there was like a green like
astroturf when we went out there to play
yeah yeah wow dude that freaked me out
[Music]
[Laughter]
does anyone in your family on a pontoon
boat did a pontoon boat is that you
can't fish on it you can't water-ski
that's just for drinking dude a pontoon
boat it's it's like alcoholics like I
get a couple of bucks together go on the
water
my cousins have one or had one yeah we
have friends over here on the lake that
some of them do and it literally is just
for like no like all the kids go tubing
it's like yeah you drinking all
get your drink you're drinking all day
yeah and I've got trust me they're a
good time I'm not [ __ ] on them my
uncle my uncle's got one we go out
[ __ ] blue Coors lights all day don't
forget I'm gonna twist it have you ever
owned a jet ski no no but I do like when
I go to UM I'm not all the time but
sometimes I get a little hanker and to
go on the jet ski when I am down at the
coz every year we got a house down at
the shore sometimes like right near the
ocean
usually like last week of August and
we'll either pick like do you want a
golf do you want to do this and
sometimes occasion up okay let's just go
and whip around on the jet skis but no
I've never owned one okay all right fair
enough there a good time checks out yeah
anyone in your family ever collect
Marlboro miles um remember then they
were big in the [ __ ] nineties I think
I tried it when I was in high school to
be cool with friends like when I was
like 16 when I smoked Marlboro mediums
but no I can't stay like it was ever
like there was nobody in my family doing
that if you think I didn't have a
[ __ ] Marlboro a red marble sleeping
bag I sure did and I was saving up for
the canoe and the Wrangler that's what I
wanted the canoe and the Jeep the Mavro
Jeep Wrangler baby that thing just lured
people in to get a beautiful truck oh
dude like I own you gonna smoke it you
had a smoke nine boat full the [ __ ]
got to the [ __ ] truck you'd have
emphysema
oh so ridiculous that's hilarious oh no
I never did that
oh that's great for a minute though I
remember people wearing a Marlboro
leather jacket they were big yes
yeah I mean like they like that was back
when they could still like advertise and
do so you can't do that anymore but I
was a 12 year old kid like collecting
cigarette memorabilia like yeah I want
the [ __ ] you know I want this the
Marlboro schoolbag and a camel yeah
that's yet a guest spot on [ __ ] my
gummy bears one time I remember you
rolled in
Care Bears want you to jump into [ __ ]
it's not it's not definite yet but they
call they asked about you you play your
cards right Paul who cuts the grass yeah
we have we have like a group of guys
like come every like Thursday went like
not yet but like pretty soon they come
every Thursday and they knock it out
because it's just it's a lot of land
like I couldn't do it that's pretty good
we have yeah we have a landscaper
they're awesome they've been our guys
for here since we moved here like seven
years ago Paulie get up on the mic a
little bit sorry you've got low for some
reason before that growing up did you
ever have an electric lawnmower but the
one you sit on the tractor no I'm
telling you plug it in no never never an
electric not no electric lawnmower
landscaper Kippy not too shabby
he's class now he's [ __ ] through and
through class you ever see what he does
his Instagram videos well do an
Instagram video like yeah just at the
house and he's got like a perfect crease
and his t-shirt I'm like did this
[ __ ] guy go through wardrobe already
right in the backyard you know you have
to ask him we have to know and I'm sure
it's I think it's gonna be a yes mr.
versi in your garage
oh now yeah do you have a refrigerator
in that garage right now no we don't you
know the garage fridge no we're actually
since like I told you our garage was
really the least classy you want to talk
about are you garbage that was the one
thing we needed to do and then once this
pandemic happened we got a dumpster here
we got like we gutted it but my wife and
I are currently discussing if it's worth
it to have like one of those freezers
where they're nice where you put the
steaks and so like you could just have
and especially something like that would
work now during the pandemic when you
just loaded up on that so we but as of
now
never we've never had anything like that
in the frigerator I mean in the garage
frigerator was right let me throw
something at you when you grew up you
didn't have a garage fridge correct
never all right well you're talking to
two kids that did all right let me sell
you you love your kids don't you Paul
you love your kids what is it gonna take
to get units and a two-door Kenmore
right now Paul telling you they're still
young enough all right get the freezer
if you want it a fridge find the cousin
or somebody that's getting rid of the
fridge well no we have another what we
have another fridge downstairs that's
not in the garage okay okay all right
you're all right as long as you're two
fridge people that's all that matters
oh yeah no no we stock up on the drinks
on this downstairs watch her for a
moment I was I was on all my opening
dates for a version he lives in the
suburbs in got to [ __ ] fridges Road
yeah can you open for me at the garden
on Mike who the [ __ ] is this guy throw
my phone I have the kids drinks down
there right we like to throw little like
parties here uh-huh
weather sometimes it's our neighbors are
just a few people so what we'll do is
the downstairs fridge which is off of
our family room we'll just stock it up
with with sodas waters and beers and
that's kind of like the the stash of
like you know yeah there's nothing
better than a fully stocked second
fridge there's no butter in the way
there's no cheese no nope you're just
[ __ ] get a beer gonna so to get a
nice pop and that frigerator is all
business and everybody knows I love it I
love a good second fridge don't line up
the door for that fridge you got a
bouncer in the front how are you on the
on the snacks for the kids as a former
fat kid I'd like to know there's a Karen
fat man what are you talking about what
do you entertain the kids with you get
them Capri Suns hi
see what do they get my kids are big on
on my kids are big on like chips
pretzels they like adore they like don't
get me wrong they're like a good Dorito
every now and then Doritos then they got
these fruit bars that they eat Oreos my
kids are really bad with candy though
man
can really bad like bad my son will eat
like airheads all day my son have like
you know cavities when we went yeah
tough one to just walk away I love when
they hit probably in like 96 or
something dude those things were [ __ ]
great steal candy not really I don't
think so I think you have you know why
because you said it twice
that's why you look guilty yeah we still
can't [ __ ] I was such a delinquent
Guinea put the warheads in the bank
let's go I stole I was with my mother
and she's shopping and he week this is
tries to do this when I first started
doing stand-up and we get in the car and
she she goes where did you get that it's
not in the it's not on the receipt I
just had a hunk a big chunk of sharp
provolone cheese like you know at the
block like the [ __ ] block and I just
started cutting it eaten it cuz my dad
used to eat the [ __ ] when we were little
and I've ever heard in my life
I used to I used to get I used to steal
he's like Janice Rossi sneakers she's
got the [ __ ] meats and [ __ ] she's
coming out of her church do you guys
remember you guys remember the Aaron
Boone home run of course yeah the Aaron
Boone home run against that was actually
the year before the Red Sox won it but
in oh three he hits that I was hammered
at a bar in New York running up to guys
that were cheering from Boston before
when they thought they were gonna win
talking [ __ ] in almost a blackout I went
into a bodega in Manhattan and I
literally just started shoving chunks a
sharp provolone and bags of gummy bears
down my pants and I just dude I used to
steal cheese and gummy bears that was
like my I was like a serial sharp
provolone and gummy bears thief the
constipated bandit hasn't [ __ ] the
sticks of salami and cheese is not that
is the most [ __ ] Guido [ __ ] in the
world is the average steal candy wheel
of provolone a piece of salami yeah it's
like listen I get it you know what I
mean okay I'm gonna cut you a break okay
this one I think I got a good one what
what kind of color cuz I know your dad
is like I mean I don't know your dad but
I know from your your you know hanging
out with you my dad I figured that from
your act who is like the most Italian
guy seems you know the Bronx [ __ ]
what kind of Cologne does he wear you
know what my dad my dad is not really a
cologne guy my dad is the shoes and
watch guy if my dad my dad my dad judges
a man on what's on his feet and what's
on his wrists that's it like you know
one of the funniest things my dad ever
said me and my brothers still laugh
about it today he's driving a Mercedes
me and my brother in the car and this
grown me this guy just drives by and
like a beat-up rusty shitty Hyundai
my dad just starts shaking his head and
he goes you see that voice he goes a
grown man it's disgraceful so we did as
much as my dad is that guy on stage and
sometimes he's a little brash and
sometimes he says things that really
upset people he did in some weird way he
is still like that you got to kind of be
a [ __ ] gentleman in a way you know
which is a good thing man that's [ __ ]
great
clean speaks and a nice watch we may
steal we may steal yeah we may steal you
know from purveyors of meats and stuff
but we will will look good while we do
it yeah the cop saw your footprints but
those are gonna be some good footprints
good shoot some people would consider a
trashy but a lot of my a lot of my
Italian friends growing up they always
did this when you were growing up dinner
on Sunday telling the newly Sunday was
always a little earlier yeah so is
Sunday you know Sunday would be and
growing up Sunday was a visitation day
for my dad so me and my brother would go
to my grandmother's and you would have
like a Sunday pasta it would almost be
like a late-afternoon type thing right
yes so so Sunday's from you were a
little different just because of the
visitation days you know by the court
and stuff but we would go to my
grandmother's and have an amazing 100%
Sicilian came here from Sicily when she
was 10 years old so the sauce and the
meatballs and everything was nuts but it
was usually earlier during the day and
then after that stopped when it was all
of us at home it would still be probably
like five ish would be Sunday yeah and
then I would say weekdays would be
somewhere between like now like 6:30 and
7:00 like the latest supper is what we
used to call it yes that's garb we
caught its supper yeah I think I think
that later you have dinner that the
shittier of you grew up yeah for sure
there was I definitely had some late
dinners for sure that we family for like
9:45 I had a couple I definitely a
couple of 915 ORS in their first Shuler
your old kid heating up a Lean Cuisine
11:30 yeah my mom work nights jerk-off
it's this you came up to identify um did
your did you guys leave the TV on while
you ate dinner maybe definitely not on
Sunday but at all no we just found out
that no no Danny like you know that's a
day and one thing I'm trying to instill
in my kids is because they'll have the
phones out and I'm like I'm really big
on like this is the time where we talk
and we're kind of talk about our day and
you know and be together instead of that
[ __ ] so yeah that's good Bobby
we just learned fully watched it every
every meal they had they would watch TV
they had a TV in the kitchen do Wow yeah
talk about animal these buckets so
Foley's your [ __ ] you know you're
sitting here interrogating me making
your balls over to garbage [ __ ] you
think we were just talking about that
yes with the cranberry dessert that was
or the [ __ ] brownie that was like
chewy so the cord would always get into
the brownie
I said how what kind of steak and
dessert can be all cooked at the same
temperature and still come out good
everything wants in the oven it all came
out alright how do you think we know
what the ass ball we're [ __ ] your
garbage trash these are all all the
questions come from at our life at some
point you know I go on a lot of podcasts
sometimes and I'm just like it's the
same [ __ ] it's it's let's talk about
this let's talk about that but when you
have like a specific show like this not
only does the time go by it's like a
nostalgia you guys are bringing me back
to some [ __ ]
I needed this during this pandemic the
great man happy to do it that's what
like the listeners are like it's so
funny they all comment and [ __ ] like oh
I did this I did it really resonates the
people at school this I think the show
is gonna be a [ __ ] hit it's already I
love it so thank you very we appreciate
that just a couple more questions and
we're gonna get you out of here whatever
you want man I'm not going anywhere
he's got nowhere to go we got him by the
balls right now oh my wife wants me to
help the kids with the homework so fire
away
[Laughter]
what was your well your your favorite
cartoons or characters growing up when
you were a little kid Saturday morning
cartoons you got a [ __ ] bowl of
cereal in front of you what are you
watching
I mean let's be honest for me like you
know Bugs Bunny's Jordan you know it's
like I mean I did I didn't really enjoy
the coyote getting [ __ ] up all the
time
not that rate cuz she just knew it was
coming I also liked it too [ __ ] the
weird was a weirdo that the rooster he
liked yeah yeah
foghorn leghorn list he's a [ __ ]
weird i'll dude that's like if fog one
leg one was a person in real life and
then was like your neighbor you'd
[ __ ] not chill like that's a fun he's
a weird off yeah he was he was a bit on
yeah he repeated himself he got a
stutter he was [ __ ] you know but I
Bugs Bunny to me was Jordan and I liked
them all dude I liked him oh I'm a big
was a big what's a Pepe LePew fan love
love that pep was good [ __ ]
yeah just smooth just smooth I'm glad
I'm glad they answered that that way
because their cousin easy to my the real
question that I wanted to ask you do you
or any member of your family have any
Looney Tunes tattoos on your body
jackets okay absolutely absolutely not
that's a hard no for everybody I've
never have you ever seen anybody that
has one of those I have look that's no
good you're not you're not running for
Congress with one of those for sure no I
know a guy I think I'm pretty sure he
had the Tasmanian Devil dude the dad
big in the 90s big because people's
thought for some reason because he was
like the rebel mm-hmm and he was like
the one who was wild that like that
wouldn't be as weird as having like you
know Sylvester yeah well it's still
[ __ ] frilly yeah dude the cat my
neighbor you've had a Wrangler and he
lot like growing up he loved his
Wrangler I was a kid I was a probably
seven or eight and yet on the back tire
yes
had to convert and he attained that was
like when I airbrush just got invented
or whatever like airbrush became cool he
had Taz on the [ __ ] on the wheel
cover and I thought it was cool looking
back I'm like that dude needed some
[ __ ] help for sure my wife loves
Marvin the Martian though she has like
ornaments for there's another big one
yeah I got Jim the church I go oh yeah
here we go
mention the trees since you brought up
the Christmas tree Paul do you have any
colored lights in your Christmas tree no
oh oh they all white lights no they're
not they're not all white yeah oh [ __ ]
I'm trying to think I think they're the
I think they're you know my wife's got
weird ones like the teal and purple
shits like so cats like like it's like
plant like I'm I don't want to say
classy but they're not like the typical
but we have two trees we have an
upside-down tree upstairs sorry two
trees is we just that's kind of being
Italian thing are they so the ones the
upside-down ones fake the upside-down
one is so we have this room upstairs
you'll see it it's like a teal ish green
it's got like it's like the sit-down
room that nobody goes in dude Italians
love Christmas Italian Italian and take
having Italians [ __ ] love than some
[ __ ] Christmas Lloyd love harrion's
also love a room that they decorate to
the skies and don't let anybody [ __ ]
sit him yeah I had a friend growing up
he had like a white we have to like we
used to say you have to dip your feet
holy water to walk it dude a white well
all Italians always had a white room too
oh yeah
white room with black trim and [ __ ] I I
love that my wife is like German and
Scandinavian and it was her idea for the
upside down
tree just because it's like this it's
almost like a decorative piece mm-hmm
but it's sick dude like the presents are
on the top because it's upside-down and
you see it I don't think I've seen it
yet I'll send you about the picture of
it but then downstairs we have the
typical either cut it down or have one
that was freshly cut and we do all the
ornaments the kids put them on and then
and then the lights are I want to say
the lights are different color but not
typical find that out for you too you
know we're talking about right member
god yes I do
another question is trees were garbage
you won't leak you can do whatever the
[ __ ] you want with another tree as long
as you have the proper real American
tree right this is everything Christmas
baby we're doing it right you can do
that so that anything on if you have
another tree that's great but you put
tinsel on the tree
no oh do tinsel is [ __ ] shut about
popcorn you put popcorn on the tree Paul
my wife won't allow any of that good
Stacey runs a tight ship no popcorn
nothing it's just ornaments ornaments
and lights we don't do that spray snow
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] what are you doing you
get the [ __ ] out of here
let's put chemicals inside just so it
looks like it's snowed in here when
everybody knows it didn't you [ __ ]
coming yeah never have I walked into one
of those houses like holy [ __ ] do you
guys have a blizzard in here you [ __ ]
jerk you guys got a hole in the ceiling
yeah and the wrong since you brought
that up just to put your mind at ease
about who is actually asking you these
questions yeah my dad used to put up
trains around our Christmas tree Lionel
trains and the one year we didn't have
any fake snow to sprinkle on it so we
used instant mashed potatoes no he
didn't he did so that's it that that's
what you got asking these questions
that's how I know that was astroturf on
your porch
dude Foley is from like a long
generation of central Pennsylvania
Hillbillies okay Foley to go on like a
first date and be like sweetheart I got
a few questions before we order this
shrimp okay let's talk about where you
grew up
before we get to the appetizer the
sampler do you or do you not sure a skim
milk say that again no I was kidding but
but do you drink skim milk um I'll put
skim milk and coffee
times and serials sometimes but now I'm
lactose intolerant so I have to use the
the lactaid milk not bad I'll give you
that it's a premium spending a couple of
bucks on it growing up do you guys ever
have Cheez Whiz in your house no my wife
use cheese was for a certain dip
sometimes but only for a special dip
that she knows we're not a regular
cheese with snob if you're there was
another person there's a decade in my
life where there was just like cheese
whiz all the time in the house and it
was [ __ ] a okay by me was wet yeah
come on well you're not a [ __ ]
jerk-off Paul you're a good guy I know
you fell over here come on I just got
one more meet you I think go ahead
does anyone in your family drink Sutter
Home wine no okay no no you know you
know you don't [ __ ] if that [ __ ] is
not drinking wine for $12.99 or less I
can't [ __ ] with you if your wine you
gotta go $20 it's gotta be minimal Pauly
spend them big bucks over here on the oh
you could find a nice bottle of $13 well
don't take it to the virzi household
I'll tell you that much because Paul is
gonna be googling it when you show up
like this [ __ ] [ __ ] only paid
$14.99 for this [ __ ] I got the app I got
that app I got that Google app I scan it
and goes his fast he said he's in
talking [ __ ] this stuff this [ __ ]
this is from Syracuse not the Napa
Valley some fat [ __ ] hillbilly
stepped on these grapes Tommy have their
shoes on when they did it [ __ ]
scumbag I've got a shoelace in my wines
people don't think I got a pebble in
this one I mean I listen I know you can
find an $11 bottle but it's like I'm not
gonna become a [ __ ] you know discover
about you know it's just like you pony
up a little more cash if that's not it
that's what the motto of Palmer Z I
don't know what it's meant a couple
extra bucks you get a better problem
baby I will
ever understand for the life of me and
this is a thing I know you gotta go but
let me just get this out no you're fine
take your time
the funny thing is when you say to
people right hey man just spend the
extra five bucks we'll just spend the
extra six bucks and get the better one
I know Oh easy for people to say when
they have no I see you with the pack of
cigarettes [ __ ] sure same [ __ ] knows
where the [ __ ] candy wrappers I see
you with all the [ __ ] that you're buying
that if you would take away that garbage
then you can [ __ ] splurge a little
bit to see that's the way to do it it
was an excuse for that you know it's
like I'm gonna save to be a [ __ ]
alcoholic pretty classy guy and still
holding up with me I don't know about
you I just got one last question and I
hope this doesn't sink the ship you
collect any sports memorabilia no I
don't I don't collect sports memorabilia
um when I was little I had baseball
cards I've given them to my son um my I
did have um like NFL people that are
cool with have given me stuff and one I
sold for a hundred bucks I gambling debt
yeah I told me that he's like you owe me
100 for the thing I was like dude I got
as Eli Manning ball but no I don't have
I don't have like I'm not a collector of
things like that so you weren't like I'm
a Saturday [ __ ] not hanging out with
your kids but like waiting in line at
some Convention Center for Mookie
Wilson's autograph or some [ __ ] never
never the only way I would do that as if
my son or daughter was like a big fan of
a guy trip and he was like at a shop
near our house and I'd be like yeah but
no nothing like that
thank God [ __ ] I rest my case
ladies and gentlemen Pulver Z all
[ __ ] class in life but I did get
arrested young that's okay oh yeah
that's exactly that gets expunged when
you're 18 okay
yeah from 18 on it's like as you're an
adult if you're making bad decisions
doesn't it from 18 on you're all class
for the rest of the things as far as you
know you don't know
what the [ __ ] grandmother's all day
stirring the sauce yeah I know I
wouldn't like have an arrant
interrogation at a station be done and
me go no no get back here for a second
maybe I was inside let's talk Jeffy hit
you guys wanna know who shot Kennedy get
back here get back
oh my god buddy yeah man thanks so much
it was a [ __ ] awesome time oh you
guys man I love you guys anytime I'll do
it and some I love to plug it for you
guys as much as I could cuz I think it's
a dope show great yeah we anything yeah
is there a semi you want the gang out
there to know that they might not know
well right now on a brand new I'm
launching it on Monday but it's
available now I got a brand new YouTube
channel of my stand-up for my special
it's got new stand-up it has the new
versio effect which is a lot of video
and stuff like that so that's on there
I'm but you can see me in the Pete
Davidson movie which is coming out I
guess we don't know if that's coming out
during this now or if it's gonna come
out in the fall but obviously make that
announcement and yeah man I got some
stand-up stuff that is now being
rescheduled for the fall hoping that
that could happen and my first theater
date is June 27th at the Wilbur and we
just don't know yet so that's a big you
know that's that's a big one and it
would be a it would be a sin if it gets
postponed but if it gets postponed we'll
have a new date but I obviously post
that too but you could go to Palmer's
e-comm and go to my YouTube channel see
everything so awesome thank you ma'am
Kippy you got anything for the gang uh
yeah just magic again make sure you rate
review subscribe as we get this thing
off the [ __ ] ground you know tell a
friend you comment you tweet us you DMS
we you know we interact all that [ __ ] so
we appreciate it
ackie miranne comedy on all social media
awesome guys @h Folio nice on twitter
and at foley grams on instagram Paul
thank you again so much we really
appreciate you buddy yeah thanks buddy
preciate to you boys